they're about 40 million lawsuits filed
every year that is 76 lawsuits filed
every minute and a newly completed
survey actually reveals that small
companies are overpaying on their taxes
by an average of almost twelve thousand
dollars but I heard a quote from you
that said everyone in the U.S should be
self-employed at some level why do you
believe that there's over 70
000 pages of a tax code a lot of those
tax codes are meant to benefit
entrepreneurs so the reason that I say
that is without a side hustle or without
a side business or without
self-employment you're leaving money on
the table by not utilizing the tax code
that's ultimately there for you